- How hard is it to fucking count?
- Nicky, this is, um...
- Piper.
Uh, Chapman.
- Look at you, blondie.
What'd you do?
- Here's a bucket, just get
it out, we'll keep going.
Lots to do, so barf, barf, chop, chop.
You're gonna be okay.
- That it?
First time down?
- My first time here?
- No, your first time in prison.
- Oh.
Yeah.
- It's not so bad.
Everyone's okay.
(funky music)
- What's going on?
- She didn't get to see her grandson.
- Oh.
- They told me I should talk to you.
I don't have a pack number.
- Who's they?
- I want a boy.
- So do I.
- I'm Vanessa.
I like your dress.
Wanna hear me sing?
- Sure, yeah.
- Please.
- Crazy!
Boo.
- (screams)
- Come on, let's get
out of this ugly airport
so you can throw a dick
in me at your love shack.
- Any dick?
Or mine specifically?
(laughs)
- When do we get outfits like everybody?
- I don't know.
Maybe tomorrow after breakfast,
you go down, you speak to the lady.
(slaps)
- What's the matter?
You don't wanna hit me again?
- Oh from here on out, this
place will hit you for me.
- Who's this evil junkie?
I don't even recognize you.
- You know what it's
like to kill somebody?
Nah.
Didn't think so.
Get in line, leave the family stuff to me.
Because Eva's gonna do
whatever I tell her to do.
And we maybe even bring Lucy in.
Who else can I trust but family, right?
(chokes)
- Who are you?
- Her daughter.
Who are you?
- This is for a lawyer.
- Thank you.
- Call this number,
it's for a lawyer, okay?
- Thank you.
- Okay.
You guys, this is for...
- What the fuck is this?
- Oh that's my treat, don't
save it, just leave it.
- Leave it?
Fuck leave it.
You can't put your sticky
ice cream shit in here.
I'll try.
I can't promise you
anything, okay, but I'll try.
No promises, okay?
- Miss Jefferson, why do
you deserve to be released?
And he chose her over me.
But I chose you.
- Hey, Maria.
You read the next part.
Put Sophie (mumbles) because
you gotta keep her interested
when you read to her at home.
And you better be reading to her.
- I will.
- Okay, go ahead then.
- Um, I don't speak Spanish.
- Great, another fucking coconut.
What's the matter with your mother,
she don't teach you Spanish?
Oh wow, that's beautiful.
Good job.
- Yo, girl, be careful
messing with Miss Claudette,
that woman is no joke.
Just let me talk to her!
- Stay down inmate!
- No, come on, man.
She don't know what she's doing.
- Get off!
Bad!
(yelling)
- Get down, get down.
Come on.
- Oh fuck, it hurts.
Get the fuck off of me, man.
- Oh, I'll be out in a sec, I swear.
- Mmhmm.
I'll wait.
There best be some hot water left.
- There wasn't very much when I started.
- Mmhmm.
Man, hurry.
This is financial literacy.
This is gonna help you
get off the poverty bus.
Or at least get you enough money
so that you ain't gotta
do illegal shit no more.
Okay?
- The Jews never put the
markers back in the box.
- So write to your congressman.
- What if he's a Jewish?
- What?
- Nothing.
- I was just wondering
how a girl your size
is gonna handle that big bag,
alone.
Or would you need some help with that?
- And you are...
- I'm Sue.
It's short for Suzie,
which is short for Suzanne.
I never prepared them
for life on the outside.
Of course they turned to drugs.
- How hard is it to get me
a board from the wood shop?
- And then maybe we'll
play a few hands of gin.
- I'll kill you!
- That's enough, Red.
Back it up, back it up!
- Hey Red.
Got one of those for me?
I gotta take a dump.
- Such pretty hair!
I did my time.
I'm looking forward now.
And you and your hair should do the same.
So, which one of these
Becky's do you wanna be?
(intense music)
- Maybe this is a bad time to say hi.
Hey Jones, what does Judy
King look like naked?
- I don't care to talk about it.
- I've always loved getting clean.
I love baths.
I love showers.
It's my happy place.
(upbeat music)
(buzzer blares)
Was my happy place.
I've always loved getting clean.
But now, when I say clean,
I'm not talking about
baths and showers anymore.
I'm talking about a clean sweep.
Clean living.
A clean conscience.
And a clean slate.
(gentle music)